[音楽]
こんにちは
川上歌子と申します
でおそらく皆さんから見た私っていうのは
普通の
元気な大学生なんじゃないかなって思い
ますでも実は国家指定の難病を
患っています
足に動脈がほぼないんです
えそれどういうことって思いますよね
あれは
格安動脈炎っていう難病で
動脈に炎症反応が起こって
血管の壁が熱くなってしまってその結果と
して
血流が悪くなったり
捉えてしまうそんな病気です
それは実際に検査で取った私の足の血管の
画像なんですけど細い血管がいっぱい
ぐちゃぐちゃあるじゃないですか通常は
太い動脈が1分すらって入っているべき
ところを私はそれが捉えてしまったから体
がそのような細い
毛細血管っていう結果を作ってその機能を
賄ってくれています
本来はこのようにきれいに動脈が1本伸び
ています
でこのように2つ比べると結構違うかなっ
て思います
私の病気は
原因は不明で
治療方法も無確立売で表情を抑えることは
できるけど
1回かかってしまうとほぼ一緒治ることは
ないそんな
病気です
私は
生まれつきこんな病気を持っているわけで
はなくて高校生の時私の人生に突然訪れて
きたものです
高校1年生の
夏から冬にかけて私は
芸人のわからない手足の強い痛みと
倦怠感などのつらい症状が続いていました
これは私の家族写真なんですけど
当時は
座っている状態から立つっていう動作で
すらも
辛くてこの時は家族が代わりに立って私の
周りに来て写真を撮っていただいたって
いうそんな場面です
当時は本来は20分で歩ける実家から
最寄りの道のりを1時間かけて歩いたこと
もありましたし1日に15時間寝てもなお
疲労感が抜けないそんな日々を過ごしてい
ました
気高におかしいねっていうことで
検査入院をした結果私は国内でわずか
7,000円の患者しかいない高安動脈弁
だと
診断されました
介護しばらくはたくさんの薬による強い
副作用に苦しめられていましたこちらの
写真のように
急激に不自然に体重が増えていったり体中
にひどいあざができたりアトピーが出て
しまったり
たった1年前まで
元気に過ごせていた高校2年生の女の子
だった私にとってはあまりにも辛い
毎日でし
た今でも
毎日合計10上前後の薬を飲んで1週間に
1回は自分でおうちで注射を打って
定期的に病院に行って
検査もしています
そのおかげで今はこのように症状が落ちて
いて
元気に過ごせています
でも
みんなと同じように生活ができている
かって言われればそうでもなくて
なぜかというと私はこの病気によって今
まで人生の中の数々の道が閉ざされてきた
からなんです
解雇を見学しなければいけない
階段がたくさん登れない大好きだった
ダンスを辞めなければいけないという
日常の社会の場面のものから人生全体に
関わる大きなものまで私が今までこの病気
によって
諦めてきたことは数えきれないほどに多く
あります
今日はその中でも一つ私を強く苦しめた
経験を経営させていただけたらなって思い
ます
後世の時は私は
海外から日本に帰国してきたばかりで
授業についていくのだけでも難しくて
辞書を駆使しながら
必死に勉強していました
そんな私からしたらいい大学に行って
誘惑に行けるほどに良い成績を取ること
なんて絶対不可能だなって感じてました
でも
病気にもめげずに続けた3年間の努力が
報われて私は大学では勉強を楽しみながら
bpa3.9を維持できるくらいに良い
成績が常に取れるようになりましたそれに
加えて英語のスコアや
課外活動なんかにも力を入れて私は
念願のマンチェスター大学への
交換留学のチケットを勝ち取りました
2022年秋から23年夏までイギリスで
勉強することになっていました
でも
2023年1月21日の今日私はここに
立っています
交換留学を
断面したんです
いや入学ごときでそんなあって思われるか
もしれないんですけど
交換留学って私の高校生の頃から大きな
夢で先ほど話したようにたくさんの努力も
重ねてきました
それにもかかわらず
病気のために毎日服用している大事な薬が
海外では手に入らないという理由からそれ
を
断念せざるを得なくなってしまいました
あんなに必死に頑張っていた私がみんなが
行ける留学に行けなくなってしまったこと
が
悔しくて仕方ありませんでした
で
留学に行けないっていう事実だけでも
もちろんつらかったんですけど
私が悪くて
病気になったわけじゃないのになんで私
ばっかり人生に制限がかけていくかけられ
ていくんだろうなんでどんどん水が閉ざさ
れていくんだろう
もしも私が誰よりも努力を重ねたとしても
それって意味のない努力になってしまうん
じゃないかっていう風に
病気上に人生の可能性が奪われていくよう
な感覚を覚えて行き場のない
怒りと
悔しさに
溺れていました
でもそんな中私はある決意をしました
今感じてるこの行き場のない怒りと悔しさ
は今後1年間の原動力にしようって決めた
んです
1年後自分で振り返った時にこの期間で
留学に行くよりも成長できたなって思える
ようにたくさんの大変なこと難しいことを
楽しいことワクワクすることをして
毎日毎日を充実させようって決めました
当時は
わからなかったんですけど
あの状況で何番な決意ができたのかなって
今考えてみるとこれは苦しい
悲しい
悔しいっていう気持ちの後に
誘惑に行く人に負けちゃうっていう
漠然とした焦燥感に駆られていたからなん
です
ねだなーって思われるかもしれません
明日は今になってもその焦っていうのは
まだまだ消えないんです
当時
議会届を大学に提出してよし頑張るぞって
自分に使ったのはいいものの
留学準備をする友人の話を聞いては寝たん
でしまったこともあるし私から大きな機会
を奪った自分の体が嫌いになることもあり
ます
だからこそ
私は今
毎日毎日を充実させようと
必死にいろいろなことに取り組んでいます
例えば学生団体で共同代表させていただい
たりその中で
署名を立ち上げて
省庁で記者会見をしたりなじみのない分野
の会社でインターンとして働いたり
他になりたいという夢を追いかけて
就職活動を頑張ったりその中でもダブル
メジャーを続けて大学では勉強一生懸命
続けたり
ただ自分がここまでやっても
私何もしてないや
と思ってしまう瞬間があり
ますそういう時は本当に辛いし無力感まで
抱いてしまいます
だからこそ今はいくら忙しくても辛くても
自分に挑戦を続けています
ここでですね皆さんの
痛みなくしては得るものなしという言葉は
聞いたことありますよね
じゃあこんな臭い言葉
辛い時にかけられても嬉しくないよって
いう人が多いと思いますで1回呪文もかけ
られても嬉しくないです
でもやっぱり
振り返ってみると今ここに立ってる私を
作り上げてくれているのは
過去の
失敗や
挫折苦しみそして痛み
医院なんですよね
病気にかかった私の苦しみや
留学に行けなくなってしまった際の
歴史の胸の痛みがなかったら今ここで皆
さんとお話ししている私も絶対にいなかっ
たと思います
それも私が
乗り越えて見に来た
議員の一つなんです
でも
病院のゲイっていうこの素敵な言葉は痛み
をいかにして力に変えるのかっていうのは
教えてくれませんよね
私はずっと苦しいことがあればそれに
めげずに立ち向かい続けることで強く
なれるそれを乗り越えられるのだと思って
いました
でも人生って時には
どうしても越えられない高い壁が
突如目の前に現れてくることだってあり
ますよ
ね私の場合それが
病でした
そんなに高い風邪いくら見よう
放り投げて
壊そうとしても
壊れないし超えられないんです
皆さんもそのような壁にぶち当たった経験
があるかもしれませんし今後そんなことが
あるかもしれません
私はそんな時は
別の道を探すのがいいんじゃないかなって
思うんです確かにそれでは自分が思い描い
ていた自分にはなれないことでしょう今
まで自分が掲げてきた目標も達成できない
かもしれないそれって本当に悔しいこと
ですよね
私も高校生の頃からずっと
掲げてきた
留学っていう目標が
敗れた時は本当に本当に悔しかったんです
でも
れた道を前に
努力を続けたあなたが新しく見つけた道を
進んだ先にはきっと大きく
成長した新しい自分がいます
もし私が
留学に行けていたら大好きな学問分野に
ついてより専門的に学んで世界中から来た
学生と出会って新しい世界を見れていたと
思います私がなりたかった自分ってどんな
自分だったんです
でも
それが叶わなかった私も今では
成長した新しいそして誇れる自分になり
ました
もし今ここに
悩みを抱えていたり苦しいことがあるよっ
ていう方がいたら私はあなたに
預金の弦だよすぐにいいことあるから前
向いて
というふうなことをこのスピーチを通して
言いたいわけではありません
と苦しむことって本当に大事です
たくさん泣いて
悲しんで
悔しがって
くじけることだって大事です
でその中で
弱ってしまった自分とか自分の気持ちも
認めてあげてほしい
私にも何も手がつかなかったそんな時期が
ありました
ただ
十分に自分をいたわったしその
辛さえも否定せずにその困るようになっ
たらそしたらその痛みをパワーに変えたら
いいんだと思います
今ここに立っている私を作り上げてきたの
は数々の
成功体験ではなくて数えきれない
挫折の経験でした
成功は
挫折のお土産ですかなかったんです
皆さんもこれを機に今の自分を作り上げて
いるのは何なのかそして
未来の自分を作り上げていくであろうもの
は何なのかぜひ考えてみてください
もう考えている中で
あ挫折も悪いもんじゃないでしょ
そんなふうに思っていただけたら
幸いです
このお話を
終える前に皆さんに
覚えて帰ってほしいなっていうことをお
話し
話
悔しい苦しい時って
何にもしたくなくなるし
絶望的な気分になってしまいますよ
ね私もできることならもう二度とあんな
思いはしたくないなって思います
でも
辛い時や
悲しい時って新しい道を見つけて新しい
自分になる大きな大きな
チャンスでもあるんだと思います
それしたら
休みをとうに
成長できるんだと思います
皆さんが苦痛に陥った際
胸の苦しみが少し和らいでほんの少しだけ
前を向けるようになったらそしたら私の
このスピーチの言葉をちょっとだけでも
思い出していただけたらすごく
嬉しいですありがとうございました